now you've lasted in this business for
so long what's been the secret to that
because I'm sure there's good times and
bad how have you been able to sustain
it's not an easy business I've always
come from a place of wanting to tell
good stories and I think that's that
I've never chased ratings I've never
chased box office I've really only been
inspired by stories and if the story
inspires me I try and sell it and I
think that sort of been my my luck and
staying around and being able to make
three or four movies a year for the last
20 years and and stay somewhere relevant
is that I'm always interested in telling
a good story I also was you know
mesmerised by the work of people like
Billy Wilder & John Ford and preston
sturges and I think if you watch the
older movies there's a lot to learn and
part of why I want to directly see if I
could take some of those lessons and put
them into a contemporary setting great
all right thank you
you